[Music]
good afternoon thanks for coming my name
is Phil I'm here with Casey and Casa and
we want to talk to you about making
accessibility easy on Android thanks so
first a bit about what accessibility
does and ultimately a lot of engineering
ends up being about assumptions right we
find that you know usually when we find
that we've made a Mis when we made an
assumption we eventually discover it
when we realize it's not right
and that happens a lot with
accessibility it's really easy to make
assumptions about what people
particularly people with disabilities
can and can't do if you meet somebody
who uses a power wheelchair you might
make an assumption that they probably
don't play soccer and this on the face
of it might sound like a pretty
plausible assumption but then you
haven't seen my son's power soccer team
there was a World Cup of power
wheelchair soccer so whatever and there
if you like if you meet somebody who's
who's blind I've heard people who were
like for example using photo carousels
thinking well baby blind people wouldn't
be interested in keeping track of photos
no we now have technology to let blind
people take pictures of things and
they're very interested it turns out in
sharing them with people and then
there's sort of the simplest one which
is making the assumption that somebody
who's not able to move their mouth can't
speak but of course we Stephen Hawking
demonstrated that that assumption is
wrong long long ago and thank goodness
he did so on Android we make a lot of
assumptions sort of I think it seems
like a lot of assumptions sort of built
into our devices you take a touchscreen
device touchscreen you might assume that
people can all the users are able to
touch the device or that they can all
see what's on the screen but of course
that turns out not to be true and so
these assumptions we have to learn to
kind of question them so otherwise they
become obstacles and so a lot of what
accessibility really is is about helping
people with disabilities overcome
obstacles and we want to really the
first thing is just to make sure
the obstacles we're helping them
overcome are the ones inherent in their
disability not the ones that we've
created by making additional assumptions
about what they're interested in what
they're actually able to do so the way
Android does accessibility is really it
depends on the entire ecosystem so we
who work directly on Android we're all
we build a lot of the core of it but we
really depend on the entire ecosystem to
make this work
so the accessibility framework is gonna
handle a lot of low-level features
things like magnification as a developer
you're not going to build a
magnification experience into your app
in order to help ever so that if we try
to do that into every single app on
Android we're gonna end up with just a
nightmare experience and also it's
something that's really best handled
down close to the graphics level we want
to just magnify things accessibility
developers people who work on
accessibility services like talkback
switch access voice access select to
speak they build these plugin services
and the ideas that they will generally
have a particular type of user in mind
and they'll go through and really
understand what those users need what
their challenges are and try to build
something that works for them but they
of course can't do everything on their
own they need to get information from
like if somebody is blind you need to be
able to speak what's on the screen we
need to find that out from the apps
what's actually going on in the UI and
that's where we really need the help of
the entire ecosystem and all developers
so this general model is that we have
these these plugin services so in this
case switch access voice access in
Braille and they're able to query and
it's an API for the accessibility
service to find out like tell me what
windows are on the screen tell me what
the views are inside these windows what
text is where what actions are available
in each view and the name can present
this to the user and whatever way they
need to if users not able to touch the
screen we can now do you want to
activate this control that control do
you want to perform this gesture and do
it on their behalf but we really need
the apps to provide the right semantics
to do that the one if I make this
simple as possible so just a few things
to kind of keep in mind one is just to
make sure that the information they are
present to to presenting to all your
users is as visible as possible so color
contour you luminance contrast ends up
being kind of the most important single
thing that you can do in that regard
just to make sure that you're not using
grey on slightly lighter gray to convey
information and sometimes I can end up
looking kind of cool but it becomes very
difficult for for some people to use the
second thing is to just prefer controls
to be big and simple it's sometimes a
temptation to cram a whole bunch of
stuff into a small area to get as many
options as possible for users and often
just trying to figure out what is really
important for your users that can
simplify things for everybody and also
make it possible for somebody who
perhaps doesn't have perfect dexterity
to use it and one thing this week we
have sort of a general 48 by 48 density
independent pixels is sort of a
guideline that we throw out there just
to kind of have a uniform standard
throughout the ecosystem and that can be
set with just like a min height min
width thing the other is to label stuff
so for if you're conveying information
visually particularly what a button if
there's a button it just has an icon on
it just to provide a label and these
labels should be concise and precise so
that users who are not able to see the
screen can find out what they do
sometimes people ask well when in my
project should I consider accessibility
so the the three word answer is early
and often the slightly longer answer is
in each of these different phases of
your project there's sort of something
you can do
so in design generally the things that I
just already mentioned of keeping
contrast control size labels that you'll
get you a long way if you're using kind
of standard UI patterns but the more
innovation you're doing on your user
interface the further away you're gonna
get from sort of the stuff we built into
the android framework and at that point
you it's really helpful if you can start
thinking more broadly about how the full
range of users we're going to use your
project your product so the more gesture
type things that you're doing you want
to make sure that there's
that you're taking into account how
people are going to interact with that
if they perhaps can't perform that
gesture during development we have a
series of api's cos that's going to
present some of those and for testing we
have a number of testing tools to kind
of help make sure that as much as
possible we can automate the process of
making sure you make your handling these
things correctly so I just explained a
whole bunch of stuff about all the
complexities of users and all these
different things you can do so you could
be forgiven for wondering why we said
making accessibility easy but I did say
making not that we already made but in
general what we want is we really want
this to be easy I think we want that to
be um we want to make sure that we're
doing that and for not please let us
know but if you're using standard
components and standard ways it really
should be as simple as what I've already
said that you should just be having the
label things we should the questions
that you need to answer should not be
complicated questions about how is a
particular type of user going to use
your project it's something like what
does this control do but as you evolve
in Moorestown standard ways it is gonna
get less easy but what we want is to
make sure that the incremental work that
you do for accessibility so it grows
more slowly than the work you need to do
to serve sort of whatever users you have
in mind to begin with and now Casa is
gonna talk a bit about sort of the way
to think about the development process
for folks with disabilities hey guys my
name is Casa I work for Phil on the
Android accessibility team so let's get
right into it now if you really think
about it there are two ways that your
user can interact with your application
right the first is consuming information
now this can be content that your user
wants or it could be indications on how
to use your UI and the way we consume
information varies dramatically from
user to user so for example I consume
information by looking at what's on
screen and consuming and processing it
in that way a talkback user on the other
hand will hear a description of what's
on screen from the device's speech
synthesizer right now once the user is
consumed and understood that information
and if combined with the information
the real-world they can then act on your
application to make it do things and
just like consuming information this
varies dramatically from user to user
and from circumstances circumstance now
these actions can be something like a
tap a swipe a scroll it can be speaking
into the device some switch users even
drive the whole device with a single
button now once you combine these two
modes of interaction we see this cycle
of action and information right and we
can see that if any part of this is
subtly broken for a user or applications
become fundamentally useless so our goal
becomes how do you make sure that this
is complete for every single user now
that seems like a daunting task because
like we've mentioned before the ways of
the users interact with our devices
actually varies quite a lot and trying
to understand those users is quite a
complicated task but if you don't try to
do anything too non-standard and you
trust us and use our api's then this is
actually a pretty easy task
so I'm gonna show you some trivial
things you can do which are fundamental
and also put your accessibility to be
much better than it otherwise would have
been let's start in the ways that we
break consumption of information now for
the purpose of this I've created this
nice little search application a novel
idea and the way that I'm indicating
that this is a search UI is that by that
magnifying glass on that little line now
right away you're gonna notice something
that's a very light shade of grey on a
very slightly like lighter shade of grey
and that's gonna be difficult for people
who that's gonna be difficult for a lot
of people to see because that's a very
low contrast ratio it's gonna be
frustrating and downright impossible for
others so what we should do is we should
darken it up and just like that many
more people are able to use our
application the goal here is make sure
all of your information is visible in
terms of size and contrast and if you
want concrete guidelines on this you can
go to the material website and we can
give you contrast ratios and different
circumstances and also hard numbers in
terms of size like the 48 by 48 now that
was kind of straightforward but there
are clearly some dramatic variations and
how we consume information and for those
situations
what we want you to do is we want you to
fill in the blanks for our frameworks
what I mean by that is our framework can
infer a lot from your view hierarchy
from the code that you've already
written but there's some situations
where we need your help let me show you
let's just say that I'm a talkback user
and I'm placing my finger on screen to
hear a description of whatever is under
my finger and I place my finger on the
magnifier icon now I want to hear what
that is but unfortunately there's no way
for our frameworks to figure out what
that means because there is no text
associated with that I mean it's
essentially an arrangement of pixels on
screen so you guys have to fill in the
blanks as app developers and you can do
that by adding a label so in this case I
decided to label it search make sure you
keep your labels concise and to the
point if it's something that indicates
an action then make it a simple action
verb this is actually pretty easy in
this situation all you do is you set the
content description make sure your
string is localized because it's a user
facing string and accessibility users
don't only exist in America now that our
user can generally understand what's
happening on screen let's make sure we
don't let's make sure we allow them to
act on our device appropriately or act
on our application appropriately so I
decided to add a new feature it's a
clear text button so you can easily
instead of having to backspace you can
easily reset and start typing again but
that's a really tiny button you know I'm
gonna have trouble tapping that and
someone who has some sort of fine motor
disabilities gonna have a lot more
trouble typing that it might just be
impossible for them let's make it bigger
and now again this works for many more
users like Phil mentioned earlier make
sure your controls are simple and
they're large so I decided to add
another feature I decided to add a
history feature here you can tap any of
the queries and see the results of the
query again now what do you if you end
up swiping on that any of these items
you'll end up seeing a trash icon
indicating that this item can remove
some history and if you continue swiping
that item will be removed from history
so this is great at all but this is a
pretty custom built gesture over loaded
onto an item with over load onto an item
and it's gonna be hard for our
frameworks to detect
so again you guys are gonna have to fill
in the blanks for our framework sent for
accessibility uses now you can do that
by adding an action or an accessibility
action and all you have to do here is
specify a user facing label or
description of that action again a
simple verb and the bit of code that
should be executed when this action is
performed currently you can do that with
the accessibility action API but we are
actually adding something to the Android
X library which allows you to do this in
a single line call with a lambda and a
string passed in so I've shown you a way
of thinking about accessibility issues
and how to address them but you still
need to know how to find these issues
and how to verify that you've actually
fixed them this is where Casey comes in
Casey thanks Agustin so I'm Casey
Burkhardt I'm a software engineer on
Google's accessibility engineering team
and I lead the development of
accessibility testing tools for Android
so as kostet had pointed out there are
many common accessibility issues that
you that actually fixes are fairly
straightforward of from the development
side and can really improve the
accessibility of your app a quite a big
question though is how do we go about
finding those issues and there are three
types of accessibility testing today
that I'd like to cover
there's automated testing use of
automated tools manual testing where you
use androids accessibility services
yourself to understand the users
experience and finally user testing
where you would actually bring in users
with various disabilities and truly get
their feedback and understand their
experience using your application the my
section of the talk focuses mainly on
automation because right now we see that
as one big area where we can make vast
improvements across the ecosystem if we
have some developers cooperation using
these tools so automated accessibility
testing until several years ago on
Android didn't really exist
in around 2015 we we launched a project
known as androids accessibility test
framework which is an Android and Java
library that essentially houses a lot of
detection logic for the more common
accessibility issues that we can
identify within an app so you
I sort of a rule-based fashion this is
an open-source project so you can go and
find it on github and essentially what
it's aiming to do is look at your apps
UI at runtime and find some more of the
the-the-the automatable mechanical
aspects of accessibility that we see day
to day that affect users the most so we
can find a lot of the common issues that
Casas discussed so we can tell you if
you have a control within your UI that
is missing a label for a screen reader
we can identify low contrast text and
images we can tell you if you've got
clickable items within a UI that failed
to meet our minimums for touch target
guidelines and we also identify a number
of various other implementation specific
issues and the core testing library ATF
is sort of growing constantly to find
more new and interesting issues we've
taken this library and we've integrated
it with common developer end points
essentially tools that you'll use
commonly throughout the development
lifecycle and you can leverage
throughout your project I want to talk
through some of those integrations today
and how you can use them and get started
with them quickly so first and foremost
we've got integrations with two test
frameworks that are pretty commonly used
throughout unit and UI tests on Android
apps the first is espresso and rub
electric so essentially the idea with
these integrations of ATF is they will
piggyback on top of your existing tests
so you have a test that runs load some
UI from your application interacts with
that UI and assert some state during the
interaction phase of your test if you've
enabled our integrations with espresso
or robolectric will actually evaluate
the UI at the time that it's interacted
with so if we identify an accessibility
issue that we believe will affect a user
with a disabilities ability to interact
with your application we will fail your
existing test so if you already have
strong test coverage with either
robolectric or espresso enabling ATF's
integration with that test framework
might be a great way to get a decent
amount of coverage for for automation in
terms of accessibility testing
throughout your
a few other points to note here each
framework offers what's known as an
accessibility validator and this is an
object that you can use to essentially
configure ATF's behavior inside of your
tests so you can configure ATF for
example to not fail your test and just
log-log something if we've run into an
issue you can set up a tf2 crawl from
the root of your view hierarchy whenever
you perform an action rather than just
evaluating the item that was interacted
with it's a great way to get some
additional coverage and you can even use
accessibility validator to set a
whitelist so if you want to turn on
accessibility tests within your rub
electric or espresso tests you can do so
maintain sort of a green pre submit and
burn through issues that you know about
by creating and registering one of these
white lists for known issues so
specifically inside how you leverage
these between espresso and robolectric
in espresso you're going to essentially
call accessibility checks dot enable
from within your tests set up this is
going to essentially trigger our global
assertion to run whenever you use a view
action within an espresso test so in
this case the view action is run we'll
perform an evaluation on the view that
was interacted with and its subtree
accessibility validator is actually
returned by the call to accessibility
checks enable so if you need to further
customize ATF's behavior you can do so
from the object return from that call
within robolectric it's slightly
different so instead of calling
accessibility checks that enable
accessibility checks is an annotation
and you'll annotate your test method or
class that you'd like to enable
accessibility checking with it and it
relies on you using shadow view dot
click on to actually interact with
elements in your UI three robolectric
tests so avoid the notation to use view
perform click directly the accessibility
validator functionalities available in
robolectric through a different class
that mirrors the same api you can just
look for accessibility util and make
static calls there too to configure a
TFS behavior
so in addition to integrations with
these automated test frameworks we've
built a separate standalone tool known
as accessibility scanner this is a
direct integration of ATF but
accessibility scanner sort of acts as a
front-end for the library it will
evaluate the foreground UI of your
application at runtime on an actual
Android device in the way it works is
essentially you install accessibility
scanner you turn it on it will add a
floating button globally to the devices
screen you'll open up your application
navigate to the UI that you'd like to
evaluate and just tap the button and
what you see is essentially a report
that describes the ways in which you can
improve that UI for accessibility again
these will mirror the same types of
issues that ATF and espresso and
robolectric can identify as well it's
very easy to take these reports from
accessibility scanner and share them
with your team you can currently export
to email or drive and it doesn't really
require technical skills you don't have
to have a debug version of your
application or a user debug device you
don't need to you don't need to do
anything special to set this up it works
not any app on any Android device
running marshmallow or later and really
even you don't even have to have a lot
of experience related to accessibility
each issue that accessibility scanner
can identify comes with extensive
documentation that gives you background
on how that issue might affect users and
how to think about that issue during the
design development and test phases of
your project so please do download
accessibility scanner it's something I
highly recommend we use when we build UI
Zico / accessibility scanner will take
you to the Play Store page finally one
last integration I'd like to cover today
and this is a new one we've launched it
a few months ago it's an integration of
our accessibility testing framework and
the Play Store developer consoles
pre-launch report for those of you who
haven't used pre-launch report yet it is
a great tool to sort of get a sanity
check during the launch process the
release process for an apk to the Play
Store
either on the open or a closed Channel
essentially the way it works is you
upload an apk pre-launch report we'll
take that apk instrument it and push it
to a number of different physical
devices in a lab and we'll crawl your
app essentially on these different
devices and generate reports that
include findings about performance
security and now accessibility as well
so ATF is running alongside pre-launch
report as it's crawling your application
and it's generating reports at each
stage in the crawl and it's taking all
of the results in sort of deduplicating
them so if you if you'd like to check
this out it's available now in in-place
Play Store developer console under
release management and you should be
able to see accessibility results for
any apk that you've uploaded to the
store since fairly early in July so
please do check that out and here's what
it looks like just to give you an idea
here this the main entry point for an
apk will show you all different
categories of issues that we've
identified will show you clusters of
issues you can click on any one of those
and it will show you more details about
the specific problem so in this case
where we're pointing out an issue
relating to touch target size and in the
column on the left you see many
different examples of that same
deduplicated issue across different
crawls of your application that
pre-launch report has performed you have
access to the same additional
documentation here as well too so if
you're not familiar with a particular
issue they'll learn more link will give
you the details you need to resolve it
regardless of what stage your project is
currently in so I want to wrap up by
talking about an accessibility testing
strategy we talked a lot about
automation but we didn't go into too
much detail on the other two manual
testing and user testing and these are
equally important automation is great
because it helps you find issues very
quickly early in the development cycle
especially if you have good test
coverage for for with our automated
tools so essentially think about
automation as a way to catch very common
issues quickly but not as a way to Karen
guarantee that your app or your UI is
fully accessible to really understand
your users experience to get that to get
that awareness of how your UI is
actually performing with an
accessibility service we really highly
recommend you go and actually turn on
talkback turn on switch access try them
out learn how to use them and gain a
true understanding of your users
experience the way I like to describe it
is automation is capable of finding a
missing label for a screen reader but we
can't really tell you if your labels
make sense so really only by
understanding putting yourself in the
user's shoes and understanding their
experience or asking users directly
about their experience only then can you
truly understand how accessible your
your UI is for users with various
different disabilities and we have found
at Google both looking at our first
party and 30 third party applications
the most successful the most highly
accessible apps that we see day-to-day
are the apps that combine multiple
accessibility testing strategies so
those that leverage automation during
pre submit or continuous integration but
also have a regular process for manual
accessibility testing or bringing users
in and understanding their perspective
on the accessibility of an application
so these are all things to consider with
that I'll hand it back to Cassidy who's
going to talk to us more about some of
the newer api's for expressing app
semantics hey guys I'm back so let's
just say that you've adopted the api's
and I've talked about earlier and you've
adopted testing that Casey has suggested
and this point you've got a pretty good
foundation of accessibility in your
application but the more you're testing
the more you realize that there's some
holes in your experience and that's
breaking that cycle of interaction that
I mentioned earlier so we've been adding
new api's and new things to make it so
these holes get plugs so the first
things first clickable spans there's a
little clickable bits of text before API
26 non urls non URL spans were
fundamentally inaccessible and
developers had to write a bunch of hacky
workarounds to make these things work
that's now changed in addition to that
in the latest alpha of the Android X
library we've added API to make this
work all the way back to API 19 so you
can
for that to secondly there's some views
that as far as the user is concerned act
and behave like Windows they have their
own special content their own life cycle
so on and so forth and we called those
accessibility paints not you as a
developer need to inform our frameworks
to present these a little bit
differently to the user and the way you
do that is by passing a non-metal string
to set accessibility pane title on the
view and again this is a user facing
string so make sure it's concise and
it's localized this is available in API
28 but we've also added this API to view
compat in the latest Android X alpha and
that'll work all the way back to API 19
and finally their headings these section
titles are used by talkback users for
example to navigate through sections
quickly and easily and the way you
specify that is exactly what you
probably expect passing a boolean to set
accessibility heading on a on a view
this is also available in 28 but and we
added this to the latest alpha of the
Android X library that'll work all the
way back to nineteen either way thank
you for your time now it's back to Phil
all right so sort of circling back to
the title of this which was making
accessibility easy we really want this
to be easy it's the only way that this
that users disabilities are really gonna
be able to access the ecosystem because
occasionally we'll encounter somebody
who's really willing to do the extra
mile really dig into their app and sort
out all the issues for accessibility and
that's great but not everybody not every
developer can possibly do that and so we
need to make this as easy as possible so
that everyone can kind of build this
into their workflow in a really natural
way so certainly to get the to get the
basics we want it to be straightforward
so if you're if you've got reasonable
contrast to make the information visible
to everyone you've got simple big
controls you're using labels we really
want that to kind of get you almost all
the way and then some of these other
api's like qasida was just describing
should be able to handle some of these
more specialized situations like if
you've got a full-screen fry
in transition you can use his this pain
title too I'll make sure that that gets
handled the same way a window transition
would saying we want it to be easy
it means if it's hard we've messed up
and we should fix that some we've found
some developers will like really like
well the framework seems to be coming up
short here so I'm gonna engineer a sort
of a workaround to kind of get around
the problems with a framework honestly
please don't do that let us fix it
because we can fix it at scale and only
we can it needs to be fixed inside
Android if you find it in this in
Android X you know if you want to fix it
by all means uploaded Android X and
we're happy to accept accept fixes but
we want it fixed centrally so that we
can get a consistent experience
throughout the whole ecosystem if you
are engineering some super custom
solution you think you know is isn't it
is an engineer working at a different
company gonna actually do this work and
if the answer's no then there's probably
something wrong and so please reach out
if we're messing this up you can file
bugs on AOSP you can ask questions on
Stack Overflow but we'd much prefer to -
we really prefer to get the feedback
that something is difficult so we can
try to find an elegant solution that
everyone can use we want the some of the
things that the cost had just presented
before he did that work the effort
required to to do some of to do some of
the things really required like learning
a new API surface we really wanted to
condense everything we could down to
like one line and so we're trying to
present solutions that really are like
if you've got this thing here's one line
of code it's all you need if you get to
something that seems like it should be
one line of code and it's not let us
know and another place to go just for
other resources is GTO Android
accessibility there's a link here to the
developer.android.com for accessibility
testing the link to get to accessibility
scanner and also the test framework
project that casey described that's
available open source on github if
you're interested to look at that
so really appreciate your time and it
would be very happy especially if you've
got feedback for us of other things it
should be easier than they are we're
going to also be out at the office hours
for a while this afternoon we'd really
love to talk to you so thanks a lot for
coming and for your efforts and helping
to make a consistent ecosystem of very
accessible apps Thanks
[Music]